[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there was a lot of news
going on and we'll get to it in just a
minute but first a bigger story that we
think will shape the country our
grandchildren will inhabit maybe more
than any other the nation's immigration
laws are breaking down before our eyes
the people charged with enforcing those
laws are instead destroying them
yesterday we told you about Chicago the
city of Chicago and this new plan to
give ID cards to illegal immigrants
those official IDs will allow
non-citizens to vote that's against
federal law not to mention the very idea
of democracy America is supposed to be
run by Americans that's the point of it
the politicians of Chicago are pushing
to subvert that if you're looking for a
foreign influence scandal and everyone
in here in DC is looking for one you got
it because it's happening in Chicago
right now foreign citizens will be
electing our political leaders Chicago
aldermen a maiya park
come on that came on this show last
night and tried to tell us that it was
our imagination none of this is
happening illegal immigrants he said
can't vote because in Illinois you have
to prove you're a citizen in order to
register to vote watch them tell you
that in order for someone to register to
vote they would have to sign an
affidavit and present a birth
certificate a passport a social security
card and potentially this so you'd still
need a second form of ID so you're
saying that in order to register to vote
in the state of Illinois you need to
produce evidence of citizenship is that
your claim yes it is okay so we we
rarely play tape of people who've been
on the show when they're not here to
respond because it seems like bad
sportsmanship you ought to be able to
respond directly to a claim against you
but we're replaying that because it's so
perfectly crystallizes the dishonesty in
our public conversation on the subject
you just heard an elected official look
right into the camera and tell you a lie
not once but three times that's not true
what he said you do not need proof of
citizenship to register to vote in the
state of Illinois
we checked everyone who lives there
knows this you just need proof of an
address and it ID exactly like the one
the city of Chicago is giving away to
illegal immigrants he's encouraging that
to take inform people who say anything
other than that are lying and they're
lying because they want illegal aliens
to vote but they don't want you to know
about it or complain that is called
fraud meanwhile in Oakland California
maybe mayor Libby Schaaf is taking the
side of illegal aliens over American
citizens but maybe to her credit she's
doing it right out in the open she's
trying to sabotage federal immigration
enforcement she issued a public warning
to illegal immigrants in Oakland last
weekend she told them of an impending
ice raid so they could go into hiding
and avoid federal agents it's like
telling bank robbers the cops are on the
way
who is she protecting by doing that we
have brand-new numbers on that question
according to information supplied to
this program by ice 864 illegal aliens
criminal aliens and public safety
threats remain at large in Oakland these
are exactly the people the mayor is
warning before the authorities get there
we'll just give you a couple examples
one is a hunter isn't citizen who has
been arrested multiple times for cocaine
trafficking and by the way for having
sex with a minor another from Mexico has
been arrested and convicted for carrying
a loaded gun for DUI drug smuggling both
of these guys have been deported from
the US multiple times they've come back
every time they've been allowed to do
that because Democratic politicians want
them to stay here because you know the
answer each one of these people no
matter how revolting is a potential vote
for them that's the bottom line across
the country Democrats have given up on
the middle class
they're not trying to fix your problems
they don't care they don't share your
concerns they're not pretending to
they're the party of foreign voters now
many of them illegal Democrats argue
from the House floor that immigration
law the laws they passed by their body
the lawmaking body those laws should be
ignored or nullified and even who
disagrees is shouted down with slurs it
happens on this show all the time
Kansas for example has a law requiring
proof of citizenship for voter
registration who wouldn't support that
non-citizens are not allowed to vote for
federal office period it's a federal law
well the ACLU is suing I think they'll
sue the mayor of Oakland for siding with
ms-13 over American citizens don't hold
your breath